hello citizens of the reject Nation we are
going to watch Andor episode
4 today John how are you too
sorry I mean I'm good how are you oh yeah yeah
I don't know what the hell you were sorry about
that guys I'm excited for this usually the most
watched Star Wars show ever to have ever existed
but yeah if you can leave a like that would be
very much appreciated also subscribe and click
that notification Bell to get notified what a
reaction for episode 5 is up the Empire is so
available for our super sexy rejects that
are patreon page along with a bunch of other
shows that we cover exclusively from the team of
prepper you guys are all right let's get to it
either I drop you somewhere and you start
running will you come with me and help with
something important and of course you
could try and kill me and take the ship
option C I fought in meme but when I was 16.
two years of it straight out of prison into
the mud I'm one of 50 that survive and who
did it turn out we were fighting ourselves
so please you were on the ground in mimbin
for six months you came in as a cook
said I know you I know the outside I know what
people tell me when I ask I know your hatred I
didn't risk my ass for the star path unit I came
for you that was a McGuffin what would we be
stealing the quarterly payroll for an entire
Imperial site this guy is always going to be
tasked to steal documents that's how you become
an intelligence officer a stolen Imperial starpath
unit was recovered at the scene those responsible
unknown sir oh [__] she's open elaborate on
these added protection requests for traffic to
the Abram sector she's on the good team yeah
just gotta keep her cool too wound up oh my
girl think of a name for yourself asean kandor
for the next five days you'll be clapped
I like the beard yeah bring it back it's a karate
Signet Luke kyber skystone doesn't take less than
50 000 for it just know it will always be
worth more to me I want it back when this
is over against two hundred thousand giving
you my word beautiful you want one of those
it's very Lord of the Rings feel to hurt
let's go Galadriel they built this
whole Mountain for this show today
rebellion and now you've got a mercenary on board
I heard that take him in and lie about how it's
come to pass you plug him in as a replacement
for anyone who goes down along the way in the
next three days if for any reason look at me oh
you've got three days something feels
off something turns someone starts to
fold you step up you lead you cancel the mission
and if he's the problem that's the advantage
of renting him he's disposable the Aaron Sorkin
episode yeah lamb it's hot right hotter than you
thought huh but you regret trying to reject them
now you will leave here and be escorted with haste
to the transfer center where you'll be issued with
any personal items that the imperial inspectors
have had time to inventory oh man take solicitness
you will not be replaced you've rung the final
Bell on corporate Independence as of this morning
oh god wow is your arm something I need to worry
about no well it's a long walk through the night
he'll walk with his legs if I must he told me you
were the boss and you wouldn't like my being here
he is something we will never discuss when we
get to Camp we're going to tell them this was my
idea and we've been planning it all the while we
never mention him don't talk about my father yeah
he told me about the payroll not the Garrison I
don't know who you're talking about and taking on
an imperial Armory are you not joining us us how
many of us are there now we are seven the seven
seven against the Garrison save your wind this is
a long walk hey hold on hold on Oh Tie fighters
they won't be back today
it's such a well Shot Show
would you [__] me I'd be it's tuck it in
my guy wow that's a great wig amazing wig
accomplished makeup artist depending on the
character I want the full FedEx report it's
my sector an Imperial Star Pass unit was
stolen from the steer guard Naval Yard and
found at the scene that gives me jurisdictional
access you've been here what just over a year
you might want to steady the ladder before
you start climbing I'm not looking for
career advice you're what a woman fool here
you fool alone are you denying my request
for the second time today fine I'll
take it to Major podcast Don't Look Down
laughs you better think what you're going
to say because she's coming down now
she'll be coming around
the mountain when she comes
there's two they'll be here in about one hour
devil goats live deliciously
you know if you take your hood off you'll
look more presentable more welcoming
yeah not like some kind of hoodlum
he'll give us critical redundancy
in all areas it's a good name
for surprises that scheme nemec
and Center it's hard isn't it can I speak with
you let's get Clem settled in good to have you
Clem well they call the help we can get so
there's a team player he's definitely dead
these Star Wars airports look so stretched yeah
I wonder what the security Protocols are like
oh my goodness wow
I was not expecting this very
realistic touch I know damn
senator's here finally we're waiting what a
pleasure to see you as well Luke and sorry
to be so late it's always right when
you're leaving everyone remembers all
the things they meant to bother you
with you see the ceremonial Variety
in many places but this is the real
thing it's a unique gift for most but
it's a treasure for the true Aficionado
break down thumbnails for everyone Arrow
I'm trying to expand parents taste Beyond
fighting implements is there anything else
that might interest I have something very special
that just came in in the back talk for real now
fourteen thousand years old sun goddess and a
serpent from the Overworld sharing the same mouth
if you can't deliver I need to know do you
think I'm not trying I never think that but I
need to start planning if you're no longer coming
through for it I found someone I think can help me
someone who to bring into the circle Senator we
need funding not more people to worry about don't
touch me on vulnerability no one's more at risk
than I am you think I haven't thought this through
I'd be the first one to fool money where your
mouth is it's a daring choice I trust you'll
have the courage to turn back it should
be a bit much I appreciate that you'll
be here are they still talking about the lie
or now this is all about artifacts we've been
mapping the old trail for him but that'll stop
tomorrow I'm pushing all our attention toward
the loaders how long do we have here I've
got a midnight inspection let's get going
I love the contrasts in this episode
from like Bonsai Bonsai dinner
for the governor poor governor
the governor of Hannah my regimental
mate that Governor that's tonight
it's on your calendar I added it
a month ago after we discussed it
who else is coming season chances there bars
Danger slymore from the vizier's private
chamber Vader Palpatine because these people
hate me they spend every day trying to undo
anything I've touched well perhaps tomorrow
they'll think twice not right now please go
doing this for you don't seat them near me oh
I've taken care of that you're at the boring end
of the table these people are fun we should find
some Gorman guests for tonight and see how amused
they are your fun friends just cut off their
shipping lanes yesterday don't do this again
it's going back must everything be boring and sad
go to space counseling it's a suicide
run that's why they only keep a 40-man
regiment in the Garrison because they know no
one's stupid enough to try it no one but us
put them to the tests the old danis Gather
in this Valley for a Celestial event they
call makani breidani the eye of aldani it hug
for weeks to get here just to see it from the
sacred land to see what imagine 50 meteor showers
all at once cool until the eye the window to the
Galaxy forms over the horizon you've seen this
I've been here almost seven years I've seen it
twice sounds beautiful it's not the event it
used to be they've got everyone relocated it's
a pretty sad Affair but sounds pretty corporate
it's a recurrent band of crystallized not to
lose a micro densities billions of crystals very
heavy but small and unstable as the planet passes
through the belt they swarm the atmosphere heat up
and explode you're taking the Wonder out of it man
Beauty English this guy is chaos that's where you
gotta go into the chaos they won't know where we
came from and if we can beat the clock we'll
be gone before they even know what happened
now you've got a lot to learn and very little
time to do it so what we need to know is
are you in all the way let's get to it
I'm seeing signs of coordinated activity over a
number of sectors what activity similar items of
Interest repeated methods gut instincts
you came to us from enforcement yes sir
here we are converted and verified information
bureaucracy let me when this materializes into
something more definite until then can find Future
activities to your sectors thank you lieutenant
I had a little smirk it's like when a
street detective joins the FBI exactly
positive note I was impressed with your detention
numbers from Sev talk far above the quote
and maybe sending more of that sort of work your
way thank you sir we're done let's imprison some
people the actors in this show are so good I know
like everyone Mr Roanoke freighter specs and the
console layout you get dumbled up it's a detailed
map for the Garrison that's an aldani phrase book
they're going to teach them how to say something
stupid can I eat my food you'll eat you'll let sin
to check the bandage and you'll have learned
all that by morning I'll take the First Watch
this guy's just so not interested I know Susanna
White and Dan Gilroy on the script all right
another solid development in the Andor Adventures
very very great stuff I'm liking the way it's all
being fleshed out because you got a good sense of
it with Cyril but then here with the ISP officers
it's like at this point in in the timeline
they're exploring when you know the Empire was
just a new form of Law and Order um you know a
new form of government and you got people who
respect government you got people who respect
uh rankings and stuff so yeah I just want to
climb the ranking I wanna I got to do my best
yeah I gotta play the game it's like people in
all parts of the world when it comes to serving
their country you know serving their government
that it's not they're not even really getting
caught up in is this right or wrong you're just
you gotta do serve Justice and you got to do
what's best and you gotta you gotta work your
way up the corporate ladder yeah and you trust
the words coming from above you that that's the
right you know method to go about yeah yeah and
I I didn't quite because obviously there was no
real Rebellion yet um and I didn't I wasn't
sure how far along we were in the and uh
and the origins of the Rebellion you know
because I'm sure there's other people who
don't like the Empire and but this is the a
very forceful one that they're proactive one
they're working on and to see how it just this
is just one tiny unit who has to pull this off
like I like Rogue one with you're focusing on a
small group of people but the rebellions already
they're already going Toe to Toe with the Empire
you know like yeah smaller numbers but they're
already established as the rebellion and here you
don't even have that established so I love that
that tense scene when they're like I believe
that there's a rebellion that's about to start
yeah and I've been able to coordinate these all
together you know it's it's interesting because
Tony Gilroy you know is the way he's always
talked about this show is like he's always just
wanted to do his own thing and not really worry
about you know Easter eggs and connecting this
is Star Wars like two uh like the the timeline
and filling in gaps and all those things yeah
and yet it really is it's doing all of that and
stronger than a lot of these other ones instead of
just Nostalgia winks and there we gotta reference
this or we gotta fill this in it it actually is is
a very fascinating detail exploration of it
all and uh that is also enveloped in a very
character-driven narrative that's very tense
and like the the dialogue of this like that
Dan Gilroy wrote this one and the dialogue of
this I thought was great there was such a great
Rhythm and suspicion and debates happening like
with with everyone in a very reclusive uh form of
Cyril who or his whole identity has just been
stripped from him everything he's ever worked
for and so I want to see more of that and yeah I
just love all the human touches even like mothma
um getting to see her husband and the friction
in their relationship uh as I know like joke
around and stuff but you know there's they keep
talking so it's usually just one lines that we
have to spew out a lot of time and uh her her
character and established like it's always been
always been told she's important but we haven't
really gotten time to really germinate and
why she's so integral and important unless
you like want to read further and and read
like in terms of the live action medium you
really get this opportunity now to see that
there's it's probably a clash of ideologies
with her personal life you know it's gonna
sacrifice uh a relationship with what seems
like a great husband you really a catch a
really supportive guy didn't seem pompous
at all or passive aggressive or anything
like that yeah yeah so I I really really love
what they're doing and I love the the secrecy
um tone that that's always here you know like
you never know who's watching you never know
who's a traitor yeah new driver loses suspicious
yeah yeah like the whole Camp it doesn't it's not
hope is here it's everyone's and then she has
to lie to her people yeah uh it's it's really
well really well fleshed out and and like to
put up that whole Act that Lutheran has to do
just for like a few seconds I love that contrast
where he comes out and he's like so erudite and
so fluid and happy and yeah it's all just hey
Mom hey I got so many things to show you guys
artifacts oh my God is that a new necklace oh
my goodness I've got an even better one to show
you you want to see some War implements go to
the back where's my money yeah well yeah it's
like it's it's funny in a way but it's also like
so real because it's like yeah you you only have
like a small amount of time you've got this driver
to worry about you've got one person to distract
him so we gotta make this quick and we gotta make
it yeah like I love that you can really feel both
the personal tension and cost for everybody like
everyone's in a really risky position everyone's
really sticking their neck out like yeah it's it's
about the The Hope way down the line at the moment
is what I get from this show because right now
everything's a little grungy and a little desolate
the Empire is certainly you know in control it
seems like and I love the little details about
that when uh Cassian as Clem gets to you know the
the base of the Rebel this little Rebellion group
and they're explaining about yeah these are the
people who used to live here and the Empire moved
in they discovered resources here so they created
this Dam and they pushed them all out and then
they you know co-opted them into their you know
uh corporate Villages and things like that and
have them you know working and everything and it's
you know it's derived from real conquest and real
history that way and so it feels palpable while
also having you know the Wonder of the Star Wars
is Aesthetics surrounding it but no matter who
you cut to in this episode yeah everybody is in
a desperate position and in a position where they
really have to give just the right information no
more no less and it's a really tense spot to
watch as all these characters sort of wriggle
and I liked the introduction of the group like
I feel like in the next episode we'll probably
get you know at least to bond to them more or to
feel kind of that team dynamic as they carry out
the mission if in fact we go those three days are
all gonna die I wonder every every season every
episode is a new team and they all die that's
the show it's an anthology of ensembles keep
remaking Rogue one that's right yep that's what
you get to steal these papers we gotta upload it
to the Rebellion all right now we're stealing
something we're stealing some payroll we're
stealing some money here was let's let's do that
hey there's a little Cassian made it out at least
yeah I hope some of them live because at least
a couple of them are actors that I feel like you
would have around for a little while but yeah just
like the perspectives you said Aaron Sorkin and
and I mean Tony Gilroy and Dan Gilroy
certainly write these very thick and
dense and very well-informed pieces whether they
be informed by something social or something more
bureaucratic but like both of those strengths
I feel like are at play here because there is
so much that is in like political tension and
just the chess game of information and Intel and
even like it's fascinating the way they portray
the Empire characters in this show I mean aside
from like Cyril and the crew being completely
dressed down and the Imperial officer basically
being like yeah we're just gonna put all our own
people in there your whole unit is pretty much
done now and even watching just like the tensions
back and forth between um um blanking on her name
right now blonde lady uh uh ISP officer blonde ISB
officer uh she like I said I love wondering about
a character like that because part of me is like
she seems like she could be really intent on this
on her jurisdiction and and you know finding out
these disparate threads of rebellion that she's
noticing and and unraveling them or she could
be hiding in plain sight you know and I I like
you know that question mark and they've again like
across the board like the casting is so great like
everyone thus far no matter how small the role has
has left some kind of impact it's a good uh it's a
good uh ensemble no I didn't disagree more I hate
them I hate them recast the show halfway through
yeah I I agree with everything you're saying
John and uh it's it's also beautiful it's a
beautiful beautiful show at the same time
all those mountains and valleys they built
I'm bummed for the show why because it's a
reportedly not doing as strong as people hoped
I mean look anytime a new Star Wars show comes
out there's always a portion of the fan base
that's screaming about why this show sucks and why
is tanking and dying yeah every time even even the
big ones there's so is someone saying that and
and this one I I think is getting affected by
that because I I do think that I don't even know
exactly why and nor do I really want to I have
like my I have I have a bunch of theories as to
why perhaps this show is not the one that piqued
the most interest for people maybe did not seem
like maybe could have seemed repetitive but um
but it's to me this is so different and so mature
and this is the adult version of star like they
they've finally they've given it to us the most
childish thing that's happened here is when that
animal peed on the Droid in the first episode yeah
other than that it's it's been very mature and I
I love the interpersonal minglings and and this
is you know like I I have heard people complain
saying like this is just slow and boring nothing's
happening yeah and I'm like right well it is a bit
of an odd wrench to throw into the mix when you
have shows like book of Boba Fett and you'll be
one where you you crave the balance of having some
of this in there and then your cool action and
your satisfying character returns and all that
yeah but there's always they both those shows
would have at least the scene or moments that
were like so playing on the love of a Star Wars
fan you know for the yeah for the characters and
certain action scenes and such and like there's
been like one action scene out of three I know one
and a half action scenes that's four episodes yeah
and I don't I like I really don't mind that and
I'm watching this and I'm like man I really like
the way this show is handled and I feel like
Star Wars is especially since Disney took it
like Rogue one has arguably been the most mature
of them all uh however there is a sort of this
like family-friendly box that's been put in and
this and Star Wars generally has been but then now
for it to to be elevated to this level that feels
more that feels so much more mature and character
driven and and about the nuances of the moments
and stuff and it does bum me out when I'm like oh
man there's a lot of people who are who are coming
around being like that's boring and stuff yeah and
I do think it is conditioning and the trailer
is made it look like it was just a Non-Stop
Thrill Ride too yeah for sure and I feel like two
maybe the tandem of releases maybe isn't helping
it either because if this had come out like if
this had been the next one after Mandalorian
I feel like the conversation might be different
definitely or people would be uh just more open in
general because I feel like now you have much more
ground to have to win back and two it's like it's
funny to me because because also there's just it
doesn't seem like this show Fosters the same kinds
of debates and it doesn't make the same decisions
as most of the other shows have so yeah it's like
all the more kind of bummery for that or I'm like
man this if a lot of people who are sick of Star
Wars who have divorced Star Wars you see a lot
of those think pieces you know if you give this
one a shot there are those people that who have
like I'm officially done after this one mm-hmm
so it's a bummer but what are you gonna do what
are you gonna do um because yeah too like like I
think that was a good point is is in trying not
to kowtow and and to just Pand in trying not to
Pander to Star Wars as a fan base and rather just
taking the elements in the situation seriously and
telling its own story within that I feel like
you do you know manage to show it shows how you
can go back to these periods of time and justify
doing so like make it a worthwhile experience and
so yeah it's it it multiplies the bummer yeah
because I'm looking forward to seeing how this
Mission goes down and obviously I'm not worried
about like Cassian andor's life so in a situation
like with a prequel story you do have to make
the Journey of what he's going through like oh
wow you know when you see him in Rogue one he's
like I think he's Lieutenant by that point and
he's he's respected and obviously that it's not
just the one the rebellions on seven people years
it's obviously a lot more people out there and
uh like yeah even Luther talks about it like I
was gonna shut you guys down because there's
there's fractions they mentioned sagarrera so
there's there's other portions already that uh
that are gonna eventually have to come together
um but it I think it is a cool story to see
this guy who's just from the streets of uh just
a runaway um and then now you'll see him rise to
like one of the the top military people of the of
the rebellion and one of the most reliable people
someone who will be respected you know I think
that is a you know and watch how he changes as a
character through that but he's also surrounded
by a lot of very interesting characters and a lot
who are not mentioned at all in other things so
I'm like damn how many of these folks gonna die
what you know every yeah every new set of people
Cassian has to link up with is gonna die except
for him was talking about Baylor regano at one
point um probably yeah makes a lot of sense Easter
egg yeah there you go Tony Gilroy lied to us yeah
how could he bye having to adhere to very specific
cannons in the world that would have been bad
right man one offhand reference is all it takes
um but yeah like the mid the way they established
the mission there is a that Heist spy quality to
it it feels like a mission yeah you know like a
real Mission show and and underdogs and you feel
the struggle so I'm really liking it and I hope
more people uh get on board with it because it
is really to me it's a great show and it's it's
so well fleshed out and and everyone's just you
could feel like a heart and soul and passion on
all fronts on this one yeah it's crazy they let
them really take their time with this one and
and zoom away with some other shows I know like
Mandalorian like yeah man do it man but go for
it keep it going everyone we're like real up and
down real weird Pace real weird pacing I'll take a
consistency of pace and tone over over there yeah
because I was like this is more of what this is
kind of what I thought I was hoping everyone would
do in terms of uh the way the character the way
the pacing and the tone is and how it a lot of the
character nuances in the mood and and not in more
plot you know well and it it seems to come from
the place of why are each of these people who they
are even if we're not seeing the grand majority of
everyone's backstory like even the Imperials feel
more human which to me is almost more scary
because you're like oh like you must have had
to have developed this ideology or or at least
had it had the seeds of it to be helped along
later and I think there that's another thing is
yeah they're really good at showing both angles
they're good at depicting the whole picture
as to you really get a sense intimately for
who we're up against not just the sort of oh yeah
Tie fighters and and Ur you know totalitarianism
but you really see like the inner workings
and how like even the people in the Imperial
uh you know in the in the Security Bureau and all
those other places like how they are really like
bound and adhered and and you know conditioned
through all these situations like it this is
this fascinating like oppressive lifestyle that
so many people choose to lead and then you know
the more ragtag ground level on the other side and
you even get moments like I think spending so much
time in pharynx for the first three episodes was a
nice touch too because you really get a sense for
just people living while we have this Rebellion
story Brewing that then Cassian will eventually
you know leave to go pursue but you know you
get that that like what real people suffering
during this you know what are we really fighting
for and then it's that you know well I think
are you you hear often the word like goals and
whys when it comes to writing characters and uh
the one other phrasing is uh one of the best ways
to get audiences on board with characters is find
out let the audience show the audience what they
what their want is what their wants are and I
think that's what the show does really well I mean
that was really overt in the beginning with Cassie
there's a flat out said like I know what you're
watching here's your wants and and that's what
gets you on board with characters and and that's
what they were like that's why you feel them even
though you don't agree with what Cyril was doing
like you you know what his wants are this ISP
officer lady you know what her wants are and you
know the the obviously the rebellion of course
you know what their wants are and and then use
the friction that uh Mata and um and Luther were
having the Battle of of Wands and and I think this
show does a really good job at showing us what the
wants are and that's why I think it it's it can
be very gripping so yeah the ones and the needs
all right guys well thank you for being here
and uh you can check out our patreon page
and appreciate the support
and we will talk to y'all soon